let's crack on with business and our
political panel this afternoon gary
stevenson is a former city trader turned
in a quality economist and annabelle
denham director of communications at the
institute of economic affairs afternoon
to you both
good afternoon thanks for taking the
time both of you oh hello gary i know
you you did my late night show a few
times didn't you you did indeed and
annabelle very welcome to have you as
well so let's talk about some of the big
stories of the day and uh
i don't know whether you have seen
what's been happening in greece
at the moment where they have now
brought it in as a mandatory vaccine for
over 60 year olds if not they will be
fined we heard a radio presenter this
morning on a different speech radio
station also claiming that there should
be here in the uk mandatory vaccinations
or you face a fine where do you stand
on this i'll start with you annabelle
well i think the first thing i'd say is
that i'm very pro vaccine i have young
children who i would likely give the
copa jab if it was recommended by the
jcbi so that's that's my starting point
but i would say that mandatory
vaccinations and this has been explored
a lot in recent weeks raise very
important ethical questions and pose
quite worrying ethical dilemmas um so
there's that element to it um but
perhaps the most concerning part to me
is the fact that the evidence suggests
that mandatory vaccinations don't
actually work they give fuel to the
anti-vac saloons by
appearing to confirm their suspicions
they turn the vaccine hesitant into
people who will just
outright refuse to get the jab obviously
we saw in vienna that protests were
turning violent when around 40 000
people were taking to the streets to
show that anger against this new mandate
that's 40 000 people who haven't been
jabbed who are mixing together that's
gonna intensify the public health crisis
that they have going on over there so
everything suggests to me that the
behavioral response among the public to
mandatory vaccines is going to take
things in the opposite direction to the
one the government wants it to go into
um i think a problem that the continent
have and we certainly have here is that
they can be governments can be very
swift to condemn those who don't get the
vaccine even to introduce mandatory
vaccinations without really exploring
the reasons why people are choosing not
to get the vaccine i think it would make
a lot more sense to invest time and
energy into communicating and convincing
people rather than forcing them and if
that fails then i'd be in favor of
rolling out incentives to get the
holdouts to take vaccines
such as cash payments or lotteries like
we saw in ohio i mean gary is that not
perhaps
the way forward i mean i think there was
a big yougov survey saying that
two-thirds of people who have refused
the covid vaccine would be less likely
to change their minds if they brought in
vaccine passports for instance well i
mean mandatory vaccines are
one very big step further than that and
as annabelle says would that not make it
counterproductive
yeah to be honest you're not going to
get much disagreement from me here i
think annabelle's covered it very well
you know we've got problems in some
european countries if you look at what's
happening in germany austria these
countries rolled the vaccine out
everybody's been up in the vaccine yet
they tried to reopen and they've seen
again rapid growth in coving so this
raises the question you know what can
you do in this situation if you look at
germany they've got vaccine coverage of
about 66 and you know um
what we've seen from the numbers is
that's not enough to stop exponential
growth so what do you do and um i think
annabelle raised a great point when we
talk about payments i mean let's look at
what's happened i think the big
criminally under undercover story in the
last one year and a half is the huge
amount of money that billionaires have
made during covert 106 billion pounds
made by billionaires in this country
just during cover the biggest ever
one-year increase in wealth that's a lot
of money if we use that money we could
perhaps give some incentives for people
to get vaccines and if you did that i
think you'd find it'd be a significant
how have they made so much money during
covert i mean is it because we had a
reliance on tech
and it was some of these big companies
that they're already supermarkets all of
these companies that that we became so
reliant is is that
reliant on is that where it all went
well right at the beginning of covert
the way the government dealt with it is
really interesting they basically
printed 450 billion pounds which is an
enormous amount of money and much of
that was used for example to support
ordinary workers the problem is ordinary
workers weren't receiving their wages
and that's because people weren't
spending money well who spends the most
money the richest people so what you saw
was the people who have very high
spending especially luxury spending
started to accumulate huge amounts of
money ordinary people they're spending
is largely bills things like that they
had to keep spending but we just saw
huge amounts of cash build up in the
bank accounts of richer people and
that's why you've seen the biggest ever
one-year increase in billionaire wealth
during an economic crisis uh well let's
talk about where uh i wish tfl had done
a little bit of that uh wealth juggling
because we're now being threatened
here in london and of course it will it
may be a london story but if you're
listening and you're a taxpayer um it
will be your tax money that will be
bailing out tfl and that's wherever you
are here in the uk but we're now hearing
that due to the financial crisis that
tfl have found themselves in
sadiq khan
who i've never been a fan of and who is
i believe actually now
holding the government to ransom because
he's saying
that he may have to close altogether one
of the big tube lines in london maybe
the bakerloo line maybe one of the
others i mean
gary how has
a multi-billion pound
uh entity like tfl found themselves in a
situation where they've needed to go to
the government where they i think
they've been given four billion pounds
already
well
quite simply it's because much much
fewer people are taking public transport
and that's massively decreased their
fare intake basically and you know
you know i'm from london i live in
london i've taken the underground a lot
but it's not just the london story you
know we've seen
the government is unwilling to give
money to tf asking for 1.7 billion
pounds but we also saw that i'm willing
to make a railway to leeds and you know
the government is saying we don't have
money to
provide a quality public transport
system for london and also equality
public transport system for the north
but you know tfo wants 1.7 billion
pounds okay one individual billionaire
lakshmi mattel increases wealth by seven
billion pounds during kobe so that one
individual could pay for it three times
over and yet here we are london the
greatest city in western europe we can't
afford a public channel yeah but really
you know but i'm sorry that mr mattel
made so many billions but i'd rather he
made billions than have the kind of
society where that money is taken
from that person because we're annoyed
about tfl when many of these entities
like tfl have billions and billions
anyway i mean i don't know annabelle i i
i i get the point
from gary that it's it sticks in your
crawl a little bit to think that all
these billionaires have become bigger
billionaires
but a part of me thinks fair play to
them i really don't want the government
interfering with that
yeah i find gary's argument slightly
well very strange in fact the idea that
we can just pay for whatever we like the
mistakes that are made in the public
sector by seizing the assets of some of
the wealthiest in society one big
problem with that and i'm sure gary
wouldn't disagree is that you're sending
a very strong signal to the billionaires
out there that they should not move uh
any of their wealth their companies
their assets to the uk because the
treasury might
seize them at any moment so um no i
definitely don't agree with the idea
that we just uh
take as much money as we please off uh
the wealthy however many billions we
need to uh plug gaps um
that are the consequence of mistakes
made by public sector officials as for
tfl it's obviously a mess but i think
that the point that you know that gary
is getting wrong here is that
sadiq khan did not put tfl in a state um
where it needed a bailout during the
coronavirus fundamental rather the
coronavirus pandemic is not what uh
brought about the problems with tfl when
the sun was shining sevik khan uh frozen
froze fairs
freezing fares like rent controls it
never works um you know and now we're in
a situation where he can't justify the
continuation of the bakerloo line we've
got uh the mayor of london um who's been
a leading proponent of health and safety
really indulging in mass theater and
having um
officials
don't forget the cycle lane so
don't forget the cycle lanes everywhere
the cycle lanes everywhere but he's
really not sending a message to people
that london is open that it's welcoming
um that it wants tourists um he's not
encouraging commuters to take the tube
because he's making the experience as
unpleasant as it really could possibly
have been in terms of what i think the
solutions are um in the short term he
does need to hike fares um if your fares
uh or the income from fares is not
covering the so is that preferable
to taxpayers across the uk
because again i just want to stress this
is not a london story it is a story that
affects everyone across the uk and it's
a story as well that may well be
mirrored across the uk as gary just
pointed out when it comes to us seeing
um
various train services being axed as a
result of financial problems
is the solution not to take taxpayers
money from across the uk
well i don't really think it's
reasonable to expect often poorer
taxpayers to subsidize wealthy
commuters who are often uh wealthier or
earning above the national average i
think it'd be much better to hike the
fares for those who intend to use
transport for london or the railway
network i think we should ditch as i
said before the mask theater and make
communities but then you see we've got
the problem again which again is faced
across the uk
the we're all told that we need to be
getting on public transport because the
world is going to hell in a handcart if
i decide that i'm gonna get in my little
volkswagen and go to sainsbury's rather
than getting on the bus then i'm
literally i may as well go and pour
petrol on rainforests and i'm an evil
person well none of that's gonna happen
if across the uk we keep bailing out
train firms and various uh of these
organizations if by putting up fairs i
mean i don't know gary what do you say
to that
it's i i can't deal with this idea that
the your only choices are to raise fares
or to tax ordinary people listen the
average billionaire in this country
increased their wealth by 620 million
pounds during kobe okay you can just
take the three individuals the midtowns
the rubbers the blavatniks they could
pay the 1.7 billion pounds needed by
help okay okay
why are you not taxing that we have a
pandemic and we we haven't got any
billionaires left to bail everybody out
i mean how did you find me dude there's
179 billionaires in this country okay
gary okay one at a time but gary gary i
want to drill down how would you go
about
doing that then so say we've got a
problem
let's not make it london let's say
northern rails need bailing out one day
right because there's a terrible problem
up in the north with the railways right
what is the mechanism by which a
government then says right hang on now
let's have a look uh yeah yeah preeti
have you got that list of billionaires
over there preety yeah can you bring it
in here please right now we did the
mattel's last week for tfl oh look it is
bill gates let's go further down the
list to g there's bill gates can you get
him on the phone please we need to bail
out northern rail i mean is that really
the way to do things gary
well i don't see why not we've raised
tax on ordinary working people two and a
half percent
while the billionaires have increased
their wealth by 22 during a crisis d do
you think that's a fair way to deal with
the crisis i think it takes to stop
grabbing richard i think it's less fair
to start grabbing at people's wealth
because what an earth incentive is there
to work hard and get wealthy if you know
that your money is going to be going to
a northern rail company but we've raised
tax on orderly working people two and a
half percent we've raised tax on
ordinary working people two and a half
percent while billionaires have
increased their wealth
by a hundred and six billion pounds
okay
what do you say to that that we've got
to take a quick break but go on
annabelle i'll give you the last word
sort of segue ever so slightly will
rather move us back to the topic of what
we do about the fact that we've got a
viable railway networks what i would
suggest we do is privatize the bakerloo
line uh as a single entity or even
potentially privatize the entire tube if
you do the former then people compares
they do specialist motorways if you do
the latter then we actually have a hope
of having a functioning uh railway
network um where potentially costs do
eventually start to come down and we
increase
capacity as is needed but we we cannot
simply get ourselves into this perpetual
cycle where the mayor of london is uh
using
the tfl as a populist measure to try and
guarantee that he's going to get
re-elected
and all the while it's becoming an
unviable business all right all right
when we come back uh we're going to talk
a little bit more about sleaze in the
government we'll get some of your calls
on air as well right here on talk radio
this is talk radio across the uk
online on dab plus
and on the talk radio app kristo on talk
radio
[Music]
afternoon it is dry with me christo
still joined with our political panel
gary stevenson former city trader turned
inequality economist and annabelle
denham uh the director of communications
at the iea and uh he's an economic
affair
for you both actually because uh uh a
story i think that's um really big today
is the nhs waiting lists they could
double
to 12
million
people on that list by 2025 due to the
pandemic
backlog apparently for elective care
could be 12 million as uh and that's
according to the national audit office
and even the eight billion additional
funds that the uh government is
providing the nhs over the next three
years to 2025 um apparently that is just
not going to be enough and even in the
best case scenario
seven million people will be waiting for
their treatment now um
what is the solution
to this i mean gary now i know you're
gonna say ring up bring up one of the
mattels that you know if they're writing
a check for for northern rail they could
write a check for the nhs as well am i
right in that being your solution gary
well why are we not taxing these guys
they put lower rates of attacks on
ordinary people and they've increased
their wealth 22
during a global crisis while we've
raised taxes on ordinary people two and
a half percent yeah annabelle talks
about seizing wealth but we're seizing
an extra two and a half percent of
everybody's wages including yours
christo and yet we're allowing
billionaires to make on average 620
million pounds increase each
during a crisis make these guys
contribute they shouldn't be profiting
from a crisis it's not difficult
annabelle what do you say to that is the
nhs working for us or are we working too
hard for the nhs
i think we've known for some time now
christine that the nhs isn't fit for
purpose and as for the nhs working for
us or us working for it i think the
messaging from the government has been
quite clear throughout this pandemic
that we are here to shield and protect
the nhs rather than the other way around
um i i do think that this pandemic has
brought to a head some of the existing
pre-existing discontent with the nhs and
it is forcing us at last to compare the
nhs to healthcare systems that aren't
the us a rhetorical straw man that
people on the left tend to bring up when
you talk about moving towards the social
insurance system like they have on the
continent is that you would seem to want
the u.s system where people suffer
medical bankruptcy and that of course is
not the case and we've seen these the
countries like the netherlands and
germany uh perform quite well during the
pandemic at various points i think it's
a little too early to say which country
in which healthcare system has come out
top but we know that when it comes to
things like heart attack survival rates
uh survival rates for some of the most
common cancers that if you were treated
in the netherlands rather than on the
nhs thousands literally thousands of
lives would be saved and we're very
fixated in this country on the idea that
the nhs is free at the point of entry
and this this illusion or this myth that
the uk is unique in having universal
healthcare when it simply isn't true in
european countries which have uh social
healthcare it's just insurance systems
there's still provision for the poorest
in society so what i would like to see
though i don't know how realistic it is
because in some quarters particularly
among politicians this love and
obsession and veneration of the nhs has
been entrenched by the pandemic when
when arguably it should have gone in the
opposite direction but i'd like to see
us move to having more market forces and
healthcare
but
gary i'm sure would argue and i've got
to put words into your mouth gary but
look you don't need to worry about any
of that if there were people who are
spending an absolute fortune on
accountants and on loopholes avoiding
paying tax if they weren't able to do
that
you wouldn't need to worry about all the
things that you're discussing their
annabelle
well like i've said before christo it's
it's just not
i personally think there's an immoral
argument against it but it's not even
feasible
or
practical to try and seize the wealth of
of um some of the billionaires in our
society for a start um some of the tax
increases that i suspect gary would be
in favor of wouldn't affect the
ultra super most elite in our society
because they are the ones who would hire
the accountants and the lawyers and the
ones who if push came to shove would
move overseas where the treasury would
have no chance of getting their mitts on
their money um it's actually you know
those who are on uh middle to higher
incomes who would be hardest hit by
some of those arguably hardest hit by
some of those measures and like you said
christo i don't want to live in a
society or economy all right gary
wealth creation because then it can hit
the poorest in society
just taking a glug of water
go on gary you're ready to go go
listen the taxes we have put in during
this crisis are an increase two and a
half percent on social insurance that's
everybody's wages everybody's wages an
extra 200 gone unless you get your
income from being a billionaire because
that kind of income isn't included how
can you how how do we make this decision
it's probably something to do with the
fact that our chancellor's father-in-law
is a billionaire perhaps how can you
defend raising taxes specifically on
working people and specifically
excluding billionaires when working
people are struggling from higher rents
higher food prices higher living costs
and billionaires have seen their biggest
ever in all of history one year increase
in wealth during an economic crisis you
cannot defend annabelle you can't
well unlike you gary i'm not interested
in playing the man rather than the ball
i'm not saying that the system we have
currently is a perfect one but what i am
saying is that i would like to live in
an economy in a society that celebrates
all right
we grow the pie to as large as it could
be right 10 seconds to respond to that
ten seconds to respond to that gary
so would i and you only grow the pie if
you allow working people to keep their
wages other than letting it all go to
the super rich and the billionaires all
right we're gonna have to call time on
that otherwise i i fear one of you two
might be on a waiting list by the end of
that uh really really good to have you
both though very spirited and heated
discussion which is of course what we
want here on talk radio gary stevenson
city trader turned inequality economist
gary and annabelle denham as well
director of communications at the iea